the nudging is the pay for insights team
so what they do is they work with policy
makers
to nudge people gently incline people
towards the so-called right outcomes to
make us model citizens and they do this
many using pay for science which is
Choice architecture and nudging so these
aren't supposed to be mandates this
isn't supposed to be about sapping fines
on people or selling some prison it's
about helping us to make choices that
are better for us I think that few
people were really alive to what the
dangers of this sort of Unit were at the
beginning some people were but it's
because what they did sound is so
innocuous and so helpful helping people
to quit smoking or organ donation but
when they really came to my attention
was during the covid-19 pandemic because
what they were doing was helping to lock
us up